[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Mark Is
With Us in Springfield Missouri hey Mark
welcome to the Ramsay show
hello Mr Ramsey and Dr galoney uh I was
just calling to uh ask you guys I own
kind it's my job but uh I I own a
business but I only employ me and
um I'm trying to figure out that's
awfully nice of you mark
I'm in the middle of my uh the baby
steps all like a quarter of the way into
it
um I've got forty thousand of a hundred
and twenty thousand paid off and I was
wondering with the business income
um should that be put into the business
first like I've once I get my my tax
account full then should I build up an
emergency fund for the business or
should I focus that on
the baby steps
what do you do
I'm a pooper scooper
okay
and
um what are you making
uh with combined household income on the
business on the business oh just the
business it's about a hundred thousand
okay and
um
God can we just stop right there for a
second first thing ran through my mind
is that's a lot of poop okay
which is one of the internal slogans
about this show but listen
listen
if you were listening to this show and
you say I can't get ahead and I can't
figure it out there's no jobs Mark is
making 100K as a pooper scooper so let's
just keep that out picking up the dog
Pretty stinking good okay all right Mark
uh all the all the puns aside you've
done them all too so you've been doing
this a while yeah yeah all right so it's
it's that's amazing I'm so proud of you
I have no idea but um
just you and you have like a route I
assume you go to certain locations and
people pay you to come to their location
correct
yes okay cool and uh and how often do
they pay you
uh I some some people pay me weekly some
people pay me monthly so it's just okay
uh all right that's fine and um do you
have a separate business account
yes and all the money that they pay you
goes into that account never goes direct
to your personal account correct
correct great first move when you pull
money out of the business account to
bring some home you should always set
aside one-fourth for taxes you alluded
to that sounds like you've heard me tell
you to do this before
yeah well I've yeah I've listened to
your show for quite a while okay so
you're setting us out of fourth when you
take it home if you take a thousand
dollars out of the account you said 250
for taxes put 750 in your personal
account correct
yes okay good that's a good plan and you
said household income so your wife is
working what does she make
uh
uh so she makes I think 50 and then I've
got military retirement and we're foster
parents so we get a stipend for that and
that's how much total come on total we
get about 170
a year so another 20 in military
retirement and Foster stipend yes okay
cool all right good and what are the
expenses of running this type of
business fuel I assume to go to the
locations yeah there's there's fuel
advertising uh when trash bags yeah and
Febreze every once in a while I have to
replace a raker uh bucket yeah but it's
not much yeah so no so out of the
hundred uh I mean your your expenses are
10 grand maybe right
yeah probably somewhere around there
maybe maybe 15. yeah okay so the vast
majority of this comes home
yes why would you need a business
emergency fund at this stage
uh for replacing Parts on the vehicle or
you know stuff like that yeah okay
do you have a separate work vehicle from
your home vehicle
yes
okay so there's like a truck involved or
something
yeah minivan but yeah okay all right
cool all right
uh
this is so great
um Mark I gotta tell you you've made my
entire week
this is so just thinking about you
cruising Springfield in a minivan just
getting out with a shovel and some
headphones on making a hundred thousand
dollars a year just get it restores my
faith in humanity and I'm it's just a
merca all right so uh you couldn't do
that if it was Russia I'll just say all
right so the um there's no no Great
Danes in Russia yeah that's it so all
right
um
I don't think you need much of an
emergency fund right now I think I would
take most of this home of the 85 000
home uh or or let's just call it all
right let's put something in in the
return so what we would do in entry
leadership is we would say take your net
profit which in is 85 cents on the
dollar okay so if we make ten thousand
dollars this month we're going to take 8
500 and call that net profit all right
and uh we would apply a formula to that
and say x percentage goes home and the
rest goes into an emergency fund
okay a retained earnings Fund in your
case I think 10 would be more than
adequate
and then take the rest home
into the retained earnings so my model
formula you make you make ten thousand
dollars this month it's a big month it's
a good month you have 8 500 we're going
to call that profit we're you know or
let's call it eight thousand dollar
profit we're going to leave the rest of
it in there for expenses that's one
thing and then we're going to set aside
ten percent of that eight thousand so
eight hundred dollars goes in another
account for retained earnings and we're
going to take seven thousand two hundred
dollars home I just made a formula up
but you can do something like that to
where you take the most of this home and
you leave a little bit in the business
and you cover expenses and the actual
expenses in the business that month
okay and does it change any if I were to
hire somebody like I I would have to set
up a fund for that as like in case I
don't have the money to cover a paycheck
or something correct
uh
at that scale they should be getting
paid off the job not off the paycheck
right yeah yeah you're not and you're
not and you're not going to hire them to
make enough that it's going to impact
you that much anyway you shouldn't on a
business success so yeah
um and and you would increase your
income associated with them so no I mean
maybe a little bit but it wouldn't
change substantially I until you get
this uh last 80 000 at home paid off I
want to take most of this money home
other than tax money and business
expenses
okay gotcha all right I appreciate it
not all of it but not all of it but most
of it and man
and and hey you know like a guy like
that is like he's heard all the jokes
over and over all the bad 13 year olds
he laughs all the way to the bank yeah
and it's just but it you know I can't
imagine what the decal on his
uh the the rap on his on his van says
right or when all of his military
buddies get together and they just go
around I mean there's some great these
guys that do pooper scooper they got
great names out there that are hilarious
oh yeah I mean if there's some fabulous
names I remember a teacher during covet
who paid off like 100 Grand because she
would she was teaching and she was
driving and delivering and I remember
thinking oh she's one of those curve
Busters that takes everybody's excuses
away Mark goes into that camp 100 000
bucks collecting dog Cha-Cha down his
neighborhood that a boy man wow there's
no more excuses left